hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the finals uh of the ftx crypto cup
between wesley so and magnus carlsen
after winning in game one magnus kind of
forced a quick draw
where he had the white pieces in game
two and now again we have
game three uh wesley with the white
pieces so ken wesley mix something up
uh or will magnus again come on top with
the black piece so as magnus already won
one game if he wins this one
then he is the winner of day one and
wesley will have to look for his chances
on day two
but uh that's um a bit easier said than
done so let's see what what happens uh
in this game uh as wesley again has the
white pieces so here
uh wesley again opens with e4 and we are
going to have the exact same line
uh up until the point where not at this
point
up until the point c3 uh the joko piano
the main line like we had in game one
knight to f6
d4 captures and e5 so going for the same
uh gambit uh as in game one uh we have
d5 bishop to b5 and now knight to e4 so
everything is exactly the same
captures the bishop we said that bishop
b4 is possible bishop to b6
is considered a little bit better knight
to c3
and now castles we have bishop to e3 and
now bishop to g4 and here is where the
game deviates from game one that magnus
won
so in that game wesley tried queen to c2
and then we had that bishop to
f5 queen to b3 maneuver but here was it
goes for the
h3 move which is the the main move in
this position and it has
many many games in the database so
bishop to h5 and now
queen to c2 is the main move rook the c1
a bit uh
less played but still unknown so rook to
c1 and now there are some games where
knight
e7 and king to h8 were played but here
magnus goes for bishop to a5 now so
again
kind of maybe wasting the tempo uh pins
the this knight here
and threatens to maybe play knight
captures on c3 and this is already a new
move so already has a move 12
we have a completely new game uh so here
wesley just
castles he says all right you're more
than welcome to capture this
uh knight here okay you can't really win
a pawn but you can
mess up maybe white sponsor not really
mess up
you will play b captures in c3 here but
maybe i'll leave
white with with uh an isolated a pawn
so here bishop captures on c3 was played
this was carlson's plan
b captures and denounce knight to a5
unpinning
uh and now uh preparing the c6 move with
g4 by wesley uh bishop the g6 and now
knight the e1 and this is now what
wesley came up with
after magnus tried this uh well idea
with bishop to a5 because now f3 is
coming and you don't really have a
a good reply with your knight for
example if you play a weird move let's
play
let's say play something like b6 uh f3
is coming
and what do you do with the knight okay
you could come to g5 maybe but if knight
to g5 uh then we play h4 and again what
do you play with your knight if you play
knights to e6 then we play h5 and we
trap the bishop so
you can save the knight but then you're
gonna lose the bishop so instead after
knight the e1 magnus goes for a counter
attack he plays
f6 again uh he he had a
good time playing f6 in game one so
maybe it works in game three as well
wesley now goes f3 as planned attacking
the knight and now
c6 first magnus says all right i would
very gladly give up this
knight for this bishop but bishop to d3
this was uh
this could have been played maybe
instead of f3 so
the move was bound to play either way
knight to g5 now
uh and here comes bishop captures and g6
h captures in the bishop captures and g5
so giving up both of the bishops
for tripling of carlson's uh pawn
structure here you have
triple g pawns and it's it's very rare
to see something like this
so here we have queen to d3 wesley goes
after the g6 pawn
and magnus doesn't even try to defend it
he just wants to activate his pieces he
says
uh i mean and it's a very uh very often
that when you have tripled or even
doubled pawns that uh
allowing your opponent to maybe take one
as the means of
gaining further development uh isn't a a
terrible way to go so here
knight to c4 by magnus and the wesley
just picks up the pawn on g6 so
queen captures on g6 and now queen to e7
uh so what do you what do you play here
we have rook to f2 by wesley
now wesley's saying that he wants to
shift the knight to g2 bring this rook
over to f1 and then start expanding with
f4 and then depending on what magnus
plays maybe even further
we have c5 by magnus now challenging the
central structure here and now
knight to g2 we have rook 8 the c8
magnus says uh this error this uh either
works or or it doesn't uh if your
attack you know has any merits to it
then okay
uh you will win but if not then i'm
going to have a very good game
so here we have rook seat the f1 we have
capture sunday for
captures on d4 and now rook to c6
attacking the queen here
queen goes back to d3 so now the queen
has retreated and now you are again
ready to start pushing your pawns and
here
uh magnus goes rook to a6 he wants to go
rook to a3 the knight nicely defends
this the attack the queen and put more
pressure on what
on the white's king's position but here
after
uh instead of this rook to a6 move you
kinda
had this queen to a3 which maybe uh
makes it a bit
hard for white to play and maybe you
would be able to survive
uh for example if the queens get traded
off but that's
uh for for another game so here after
queen to d3 like i said rook to a6 was
played but now wesley continues with his
plan
and pushes f4 so what do you play here
obviously you can capture here but uh
magnus decides against this he tries
first
rook to a3 with an attack on the queen
maybe you can
capture later on queen the g6 and
now you could capture but again if you
capture on f4
then for example rook captures rook
captures and knight captures and this is
just
really really bad for black you have a
past pawn here that's already on e5 you
have a knight and a queen here in front
of the black king and
not much to be done here if you try
something let's say you move the knight
then rook to c1
just you know gets the rook to a
beautiful
open c file here uh and the the d5 pawn
is under attack i mean white can just
choose
any move uh that white white wants to
play here there really isn't a good move
you can play here
knight also just immediately going for
that d5 pawn it's uh
it's a hopeless position for black so
instead after this queen to g6 we have
rook captures on h3 by magnus
and now can he do something along this h
file maybe
well wesley says uh i don't care i'm
just going to continue pushing my pawns
he plays f5
uh king to h8 and now f6 magnus was
expecting this so
he wants to play captures captures and
then queen to h7 which means
that after this is played and it has
been played magnus does play queen to h7
and now offers a queen trade
but also threatens checkmate this is
what he was going for
but this unfortunately doesn't work so
feel free to pause the video here and
tie the match or rather win the game for
wesley while i give you a couple of
seconds
matter really snoring back there if you
can hear him
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that
the winning move is to just trade the
queens and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's queen to g7
with
check and it was in this position on
move 33 that magnus carlsen resigned to
the game and the wesley has bounced back
and is now back into the match so i
i can't remember if the previous uh if
the game that magnus one was also 33
moves maybe 32 moves
uh
yeah it was 33 moves very interesting
and also now
wesley wesley hits back with a 33 move
win
with the white pieces so really really
awesome stuff yeah
uh that's that ties the match there's
still game four where magnus will have
the white pieces so he's gonna have to
try something else and
you know he will not be able to just
play for a quick draw with white
uh but we'll see uh we'll see what
happens or if this will
shake him up uh as now wesley you know
it's never pleasant when your opponent
bounces back
uh but at least uh you know he bounced
back and now you have the white pieces
it's pretty
it's really bad where your opponent
bounces back and then you have the black
pieces in the final game
uh but yeah that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
hiriki
lapiguchi uh suresh kota mario balochi
aditya kiran kumanduri and dandejong for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day